do you believe i got mocked for playing
video games in school and now it's just
like the accepted past time right i got
so much [ __ ] for that that's weird
because
in my school video games were quite
normalized was it just your school
maybe did you no no i got rinsed to my
school unless you're playing fifa
or cod which i was and i still got rids
what like i would be sitting in my room
in university playing some rpg
hoping that nobody opens the door to
discover the fact that i was playing
i was playing jrpgs i think if i came
out
saying that i was a massive jrpg fan
where i was you know playing persona 3
or something
yeah i probably would have gotten beaten
up as well but i got so much [ __ ] for
playing runescape and i still to this
day
really i think i love runescape i
remember some videos popped up in my
recommended recently
and i had a great time watching them
because i got because in my school
i think my my group of friends we were
more so than not i guess like the
the nerdy group of friends yeah so we so
a lot of my friends from high school got
me into games like like runescape
like starcraft uh you know other just
like land games like civilization like
those games back in the day but when it
came to anime
i think i had a really tough time
because i was literally the only
asian kid in my school oh no same way i
was the only asian kid in my school with
like any amount of asians
but like i'm not even like full blood
asian but it's just like oh
this boy's a little bit oriental
he's rice what the hell yeah so i i was
i think i was a closet anime fan for
man i want to say like majority of my
high school life
but then my group of friends who got me
into like starcraft and runescape i was
like okay you guys are nerdy enough
maybe i can try and convince them to
watch something and i convinced one of
my friends to watch ava
oh so i was like why ava yeah that's not
really the uh
gateway anime i would think of don't
know maybe because i had was recently
re-watching ava
yeah and i thought okay this is probably
normie enough
no that they could maybe give me some
recommending ava
as someone's first anime that could go
one of two ways yeah and it's not
there's gonna be no middle ground either
he's going to think this is amazing and
he's a fan but the thing is i didn't
want to get them into like
naruto or one piece or dragon ball to
start with because
we all know if your gateway anime is one
piece
naruto or dragon you're gonna be
announcing all you're gonna be talking
about for the rest of your career so
hey man i don't know man i mean i got in
through naruto
but i mean i i remember the point where
you got it i got it i got it
there there was there was the point when
i would only watch shonen and i know
exactly
the exact phase you're talking about
yeah and then you figure out
that huh there's other things outside of
shonen that
are pretty cool in this medium and some
people i guess just never figure that
out
i feel like naruto fans are like the
british with food it's like
no no no potatoes is all we need
spice what is it about what is about
what is it about like it's not obviously
not
all shown in fans but a lot of shonen
fans who as you said like
get into say naruto yeah just
exclusively talk about naruto's like
what is it i want to know what their
mentality is right with anime where it's
like do they just think that
everything that's not naruto is just
hentai like
there's like no no there's no in-between
it's either shonan or just like straight
up r18
[ __ ] like they're like what is it what
is this high school romance [ __ ]
i don't want to feel i want to feel i
want to feel one emotion and that's hype
shoujo it must be the thing of like i
get it because the type is [ __ ] but like
they just must want hype their whole
life like just being like a crack addict
yeah right
like you you only want to feel that high
you get from crack it's like it's like
steroids this is just for the eyes
yo e3 it was crazy this year every game
every game
i'm hyped for every game and then they
don't play any of them
like the next modern warfare yeah but in
the moment there's like a bad
news article about the game that just
came out in e3 they're like yeah i knew
it was [ __ ]
the whole time the whole time yeah no so
like my anime friend
i i got so there was a group of them it
was like me and maybe
uh like i'd say like six or seven guys
who i used to like really really close
to hang out with in high school
and i got one of my friends who got me
into like starcraft
i got him to watch ava and i i wanted to
try that just with one person i didn't
want to like bring
a whole group of people into the nice
group viewing so i kind of was just like
any meaning
i got you watch ava and he was like okay
i'll give it a go and he was kind of mad
about it at first i like
i like anime and i i was like at points
like kind of like yeah
and that was the one where i was like oh
gateway anime are important
and ava is not that always definitely
you can never go wrong with death
yeah so i think i think that one friend
he he watched ava
and then he eventually found death note
yeah and he and
and one piece and those like the two
shows that he heavily gone into so i was
like okay
then maybe i can try it out with the
other boys hey watch death no watch one
people's boys
there was boys before us these are the
og
boys do you know what the do you know
what the name of our like
this is gonna be really cringy but that
we had like a group
name what was the name joey it was the
[Music]
we were called hbk because we were
did you guys ever play handball in
school i think that's an australian i
think that's an australian thing so in
australian schools we play handball but
not like the olympic sport handball like
like
school grounds handball but usually most
kids in australia
stop playing handball by around like
sixth grade right so it's very rarely
you go into middle school
and play handball we played handball all
the way until high school graduation and
we were the only ones and so
from nowhere we were called hbk which is
the handball crew
[Laughter]
and we were through with the k you were
the cause and and
it's not like and and it was just out of
nowhere one day
just the other boys in our year just saw
us playing handball and they were like
hbk
and we're like what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] does that mean we later found that
man handball crew
and normal people would be like oh
that's [ __ ] cringy yeah we were like
handball hell yeah
i think i think handball is something
i've only heard australians play in
their school because oh yeah i've seen
obviously he's seen handball in the
olympics and everything like yeah
when we had like a british team like
when did they play that i know right
but it's completely different to the
olympic sport yeah so so when i saw
handball
because i'd always known handball as
that thing that you play in school
where it's like four white squares and
you kind of like yeah it's it's
basically just tennis but with your hand
yeah and a tennis ball and in really
confined space so when i saw handball
the olympic sport i was like what the
[ __ ] is this
this isn't handball no it's really
interesting to hear you say going back
to the anime um
conversation that we were having because
i didn't even make my first anime friend
till i started youtube like that was
years after i started youtube i didn't
start
talking to other people who liked anime
until
the age of the internet where i
literally started talking to other
people who reviewed anime
right right because back when i was in
school and especially when i was in
university
i did everything i could to keep it
under wraps
like this even in uni even in uni it was
like
top secret confidential if you find this
out
i'm i'm i'm gonna change my identity or
something like that
i remember someone walked into my room
of me watching no game no life in
university and
it was the moment of like how do i okay
how do i explain
what's going on here because one of the
bad scenes as well